docteur bertrand galichon urgentiste à
l'hôpital lariboisière bonsoir bertrand
galichon merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france auger l'une de vos
interviews vous êtes firme y ait un pic
serait attendu dans les deux trois jours
en tout cas un afflux de paix sur
veuillez m'excuser puisque les mots ont
leur importance
vous pensez donc ça sera un afflux
important dans deux trois jours de
patients accueillis dans les hôpitaux
écoutez tous monsieur à lariboisière
donc prenez gare du nord à paris
je peux vous donner le témoignage à
partir de cet endroit
la semaine a été calme enfin au moins
des flux des patients arrivant aux
urgences mais on les a vus arriver de
plus en plus nombreux et surtout on sait
de préparer de façon extrêmement active
à l'afflux que nous attendons pour ce
week end je peux pas vous dire si ça
sera demain matin ou dimanche matin
mais voilà on est certain que là on va
avoir un afflux de deux personnes
susceptibles d'être touchés par le col
un virus important pour quelle raison ce
sentiment vous avez laissé les chiffres
épidémiologique c'est l'évolution des
courbes que l'on voit arriver depuis le
plus grand un stick a été touché avant
nous on voit bien les chiffres qui
doublent très régulièrement toutes les
48 heures on aurait bien qu on va être
devant un pic très important dans les
prochains jours ou début de semaine
prochaine
ça veut dire que ce sont des personnes
nouvellement contaminées qui alors que
les dons
les mesures de confinement n'était pas
encore mises en oeuvre et qui se
seraient contaminés justement en étant
un petit peu insouciant il y a quelques
jours de cela alors il ya le biais fakir
entre ligne de compte
il ya aussi les gens qui ont été
contaminés qui ce qu'ils sont qui
s'aggrave et qui va falloir prendre en
charge et qui sont encore chez elle et
puis il ya des nouveaux qu'un parce que
je ne pense pas que les mesures que nous
emprise de confinement et était
totalement hermétique
c'est à dire vous pensez qu'à un
confinement plus stricts seraient
souhaitables aujourd'hui alors je pense
pas qu'on puisse aller raisonnablement
beaucoup plus loin sinon que nous mettre
directement tous sous cloche je crois
que ce qui est fait raisonnable ce matin
j'ai pris j'ai pris le métro
eh bien nous étions deux dans la rame de
métro alors à une heure où normalement
nous sommes nous sommes lésés centaines
je ne pense pas qu'on puisse aller plus
loin dans le on entendait le témoignage
d'un médecin français qui se trouvent en
chine le docteur philippe klein ce
témoignage a été publié par de nombreux
médias français qui en gros 10 et voilà
si on ne fait pas comme les chinois si
on ne respecte pas des mesures
absolument drastiques
le bilan pourrait être terrible encore
plus lourd vous ne partagez pas ce
diagnostic de votre confrère français
qui se trouvent à one précisément et là
je pense qu'il faut il faut gérer la
crise au jour le jour en anticipant sa
montée de certaines il faut tenir compte
des différences de culture entre l'asie
et l'europe l'asie et très et
culturellement très structurée par le
groupe alors que nous ne sommes plus
structurée autour la personne lors de
l'un des 18 autres choses sont
complètement différentes la gestion
n'est pas la même nos régimes politiques
ne sont pas les mêmes donc la gestion ne
peut pas être nous tempère notre part je
crois que il ne faut pas rajouter un sur
accident à l'accident initial
je crois que tout le mouvement de
panique serait extrêmement héritèrent
pense qu'il faut c'est très un arm
je pense qu'il faut tenir compte les
principes de précaution et puis celui d'
incertitudes parce qu'on est devant
quelque chose de tout à fait nouveau
enfin au moins pour notre notre
génération
je pense qu'il faut garder garder son
calme et je pense à l'heure actuelle en
europe
enfin au moins en france les choses
semblent être gérée de façon correcte en
fonction de ce que l'on sait est-ce que
l'une des solutions pour vous passera
par davantage de tests comme l'ont fait
certains pays asiatiques
alors moi je pense que c'est
effectivement une solution une solution
intéressante c'est que il faut que les
tests soient sérologique soi et les
prélèvements naso soit soit diffusée
plus largement
et puis je crois qu'il faut aussi que
nous puissions alors ce travail dès
maintenant au niveau de l'hôpital
trouver les tests radiologiques sont
vertes ou ça qui puisse nous permettre
plus facilement de confirmer où il
affirmait la gravité d'un patient touché
par le commandant viol merci beaucoup
docteur bertrand guay michon d'avoir été
en direct avec nous sur rt france merci
à vous et surtout bon courage dans votre
mission